hey everybody and welcome to a properly
epic
wild ride with stevo we've got duncan
trussell a comedian a podcaster and the
star of the netflix show of midnight
gospel
but what makes it so epic well i've
called different episodes different
things i said that our tiffany haddish
episode was the best one we had recorded
t-pain i said was the juiciest one jim
jeffries i said was the funniest one
well ladies and gentlemen this episode
is
my personal absolute favorite of
all of them that we have done to date
why because i got to talk to him
about stuff that i am not at all
comfortable talking about with most
people
and that means so much to me we get
real into hardcore drugs and
spirituality and it's all just fun
and funny and i really fell in love with
this guy
and so will you so let's get into it
dude i love that you got a dope ass
microphone too
so i gotta have one i podcast you got
one too sure
sm7b it's the standard it doesn't help
me
sound any less shitty but uh we got to
sit friend
how many times online if i've been told
that i sound like you oh wow
really epic oh yes well hey as they say
let's not leave it in the hall so if
you're ready man i'm gonna
we'll dive right in oh i'm ready yeah
okay
ladies and gentlemen duncan trussell
hello yeah dude allow me to introduce
you to my co-host
scott randolph what's going on dt great
to meet you scott
and up at the front of the van we've got
the gorgeous paul briskey
hello duncan how are you what's up
gorgeous oh thank you
jealous i'm jealous you did the thing
this is the thing like though it's the
ultimate thing where you put your
podcast studio in
the van it's final phase
it's awesome who's uh who's who's beat
us to this because i was feeling pretty
confident that the wild ride was
was all us um well tom green
this has been going on since before tom
started the van life but of course
let's pay homage to the king who started
podcasts
in general good point
i didn't mean anyone beat you i just
mean like you know when you're
fantasizing about the freedom
around podcasting and you you naturally
start thinking [ __ ] what if i just put
the whole thing
in a van and travel around the country
this is before i have kids now i can't
do that but in
in the old days when i was addicted
academy that was like that
i'll just put all my modular scents in
the [ __ ] thing drive
you don't get much further than drive oh
yeah it seems like a kick
oh where are you is this are you in l.a
we are yes since this is on zoom
we're uh simply parked where we normally
park
but uh yeah i love a lot of things you
just said i really uh
like got turned on by like addicted to
ketamine
[ __ ] love ketamine i can't have it i
can't have it anymore either
but best god
i i wasn't very cool on it but i
[ __ ] thought i was but it felt cool
but so that's one of the that's one of
the weird things about ketamine is it
gives you this bizarre
like narcissism like it may really like
[ __ ] with your like ability to
oh dude what it is is uh
like pharmaceutical pcp
it falls in the class of drug known as
dissociative yeah and uh pcp is a much
like dirtier
street version but they they have a lot
in common
hold on writing down need to try pc
oh my god i did i was about equally uh
uh
out there on both um another thing i
want to zero in on
that uh you know you described the idea
of putting it all into a van
as like the ultimate freedom but that
was so not my motivation dude like
my motivation was like you know this
whole podcast bandwagon
where i mean dude honestly having a
podcast is about
like having a [ __ ] instagram account
these days i mean
everybody has one it's embarrassing and
because everybody has a podcast it's
always been the most annoying question
that
anybody could really ask me among them
anyway
like will you do my podcast i'm thinking
oh okay so well i can't
well well i like you know screw up an
entire day to come sit down with you and
talk to ourselves
well look this is the gift of covet
though because to me
like there was this uh a pretty
superstitious idea floating around which
is
you gotta be in the room to really do a
good podcast
you gotta spell their pheromones you
gotta like breathe in their
mouth and then you can connect and you
know i think there's something to be
said for that musk inhalation theory but
also
yeah the the this doesn't uh disrupt it
too much we've had some really [ __ ]
good ones on zoom
man like uh tiffany haddish had us like
just about crying i mean anybody
listening to this check out the tiffany
hatties episode
i said it was the best one we ever did
are you saying that that's what i said
at the time
yeah but in any case the reason why i
wanted to move it into a van was because
knowing how much it's annoyed me over
the years people trying to get me on
their podcast
i just like had a lot of resistance to
bringing that question to people myself
so i thought if i could put it all into
a van then just say hey
you know whenever and wherever it's
convenient for you we'll just show up
you hop in it's going boom get out we'll
make it so easy for you
so the idea of a portable studio was
it's like
bang bus it's a verbal bang bus
you are watching bang bus and you're
like [ __ ] i think this will work for
podcasts
like this format i'm so glad that you
mentioned bang bass because back in the
day
thank god you mentioned bang bang but
yeah i mean think about this let me run
this by all what's bang bus
i'm just kidding okay i'm gonna run
something by all of you guys right now
you tell me if my theory is correct
okay okay prostitution is
illegal okay but what if
on the bang bus you've got an ordained
minister
so you get on the bus you pick out a
lady
and you ask that lady to marry you now
the ordained minister officially marries
you so now you are
husband and wife you consummate the
marriage
on the bus and then when you're done
having sex then you think the better of
it and in all the marriage and then you
get off the bus
once again unmarried have i not just
legalized prostitution well do you pay
her at some point
in the settlement i mean i think that in
knowing the marriage i think that out of
respect you might
want to uh have some kind of a
settlement yeah you want a
divorce settlement yeah i think you've
come up with your show it's like some
combination
judge judy you gotta get a judge in
there
you know so it's like right you could
have a contentious divorce who knows
how how does that idea come about like
steve's like like
watching you know bang bust he's like
dude i would marry that chick and then
he busts a nut he's like
nah i wouldn't want to marry that
chicken think about that
i don't know i just thought i mean i
think that i think that my
my [ __ ] theory holds water dude i
really do
yeah i do i think you figured it out
like for sure why does that be limited
to a bus i mean
you could grab a bra it could be like a
conveyor belt where like
phase one you get married then you just
slide along you bang and then you slide
along to divorce court
i mean talk about the vegas chapel i
mean right dude
like i just got to move it over to reno
i like that
cool afternoon
[ __ ] you go through a bad divorce
yeah that's a roller coaster of a day
it's alright it could
can we get back to the k hole because
i've never i've never been in a thank
you
thank you scott i'm so glad i'm curious
about it like
what's it like what's what are your
guys's like worst k experiences
or like best but when you're in a k hall
how long does it last
what are you thinking are you thinking
you're going to die are you tripping or
are you loving it
i think that that's the the general big
picture answer
is that it that it's a real moving
target man it's
like uh various experiences like are
the various you know i mean like i i can
but you first man
and i'll take it away uh let's not
go for best or worse experience but just
notable
um well you know what i'm gonna look it
up real quick and see if i can find it
the guy who invented float tanks
was really into ketamine and he actually
created a
yeah here it is it's so funny he did
this but he created a dosage
chart where he actually
mapped the experiences out based on
milligram dosages if you look it up just
john lily ketamine chart
so he's got here now i don't know
because i was like
insulating i have no idea like what the
what the injection
what this means compared to like
snorting it but at 30 milligrams you've
got
something he's calling internal reality
75 milligrams which he
which he calls i 75 milligrams a day
extraterrestrial reality 150 milligrams
we the network of creation and then 300
milligrams
unknown can you overdose on ketamine oh
my god
i gotta say i love everything about this
conversation that we're having
and i also really love the message that
i have for you right now
because well over a year ago out of
nowhere
one of my buddies said dude you should
check out this company called
harry's they make these awesome shaving
products that don't cost
so much and i thought that's kind of
weird but i remembered it
and then lo and behold i was in target
and i saw
harry's on the shaving aisle sitting
right next to all these other products
that
are really obnoxiously overpriced which
i had been wasting my money on
i thought hmm let me just buy it and
check it out
and i swear i have been using nothing
but
harry's shaving products ever since
and i love them because they look great
they
work great and the company believes in
it so much
that they got a 100 money back guarantee
they also have
the best deal for listeners of wild ride
with stevo what's the deal
you're going to get a whole starter kit
which comes with the 5 blade razor
a weighted ergonomic handle foaming
shave gel
and a travel blade cover which is a 13
value i know it sounds crazy compared to
all those other companies but that's how
reasonably priced they are
13 bucks except you get it for
three bucks so how do you get it you go
to harrys.com
stevo to get this killer starter kit i
swear by it so much
and i love that they're sponsoring my
podcast now because i have been
religiously loyal to harry's
for well over a year i love it you're
gonna love it
so get this killer deal at harry's dot
com
slash stevo thank you harry's and thank
you
for being a listener now let's talk
about ketamine
i'm so excited to talk to you duncan i
mean honestly i had like
i'm so excited on so many levels and um
like like what you just described there
really i think reinforces my personal
experiential theory that there's
something
absolutely spiritual in in drugs and
particularly even in ketamine
but oh god ketamine is like um one of my
friends who writes all these books on
the occult
calls it occult cocaine it's a it's such
a occult
substance it's a you know something
about the disassociative
effect uh it opens up i mean you can
call it whatever you want but i think
it's a
i think i think you you go into
alternate universes
sure here's what i think is that
that like we are sort of relegated to
this
physical reality or sorry physical
illusion
in this third dimensional sort of
compartment
and i believe that when we ingest
you know certain chemicals and a variety
of chemicals that what we do is we
essentially
erode the barriers in between said
apartments and kind of open ourselves up
to
entities from other dimensions it's a
dangerous thing to do with drugs
because with with drugs like when you
those those barriers that we are eroding
are essentially
protective in a number of ways and by
eroding the barriers we open ourselves
up to sort of uh all
you know all things you know other
dimensional and that
comes with a lot of like very low
frequency
and low frequency i would categorize as
deep demonic you know like demons and
high
frequency being like sort of angels so
when i was you know at the end of my run
with drugs and alcohol i was
like [ __ ] routinely and i was so
excited about it because i felt privy to
what was going on
like in other dimensions with spiritual
beings
so i just couldn't keep piling in enough
drugs to keep it happening like the the
the hallucinations that i was having
both visual like hearing the voices you
know
uh audio uh like
tactile where you actually feel it you
know and and i ha
i categorized all of the experiences
with these beings
as demons and angels and then the third
category which i
now think of as demons trickster spirits
where they they were just
straight trying to [ __ ] entertain me
and boy did they
because like i was like sitting in a
chair i remember i was like snorting
cocaine i was
inhaling nitrous oxide i had all pills
weed everything and i just thought to
myself
as i went to go do this line of cocaine
i just thought there's no longevity in
this like i'm straight
killing myself right now yeah and then i
had to thought
[ __ ] it i don't care like i don't care
if i die i had that thought i don't care
if i died lean over to do this line of
cocaine
and the swiveling office chair that i
was in
as i leaned over it physically
spun around like a big strong dude grab
it and
like with the force of like a mechanical
bull and
now i know intellectually for a fact
that i did not actually spin if there
was a surveillance camera in my
apartment nothing would have happened
but i'm telling you i had that
experience a very tactile experience
and there was another time sitting in
that same exact chair the whole [ __ ]
chair
just straight erupted into flames and
like every time i had one of these
experiences
i'm like okay this is [ __ ] cool you
know this is going on let me double
check is it
yeah i just double checked and it's
still going on
the flames all engulfing me it's not hot
i'm perfectly comfortable but it's just
really [ __ ] cool that i happen to be
in a chair engulfed in flames
like i had this skateboard screwed to
the wall
uh so it was uh you know vertical right
and i had a globe
ma screwed to the skateboard so the
globe was protruding over the doorway to
the apartment
you know like uh horizontally and
i like like the [ __ ] liquid
terminator i watched that globe
like my own face like pushed through it
you know like like it was the liquid
terminal you could see my face
push through it and then [ __ ] it just
started [ __ ] headbanging
and i'm like [ __ ] right on you know
i had these curtains do it just on their
own open and close and open and close
where that wasn't possible there were
lights that were never [ __ ] there
that was just flashing like it just
turned into a [ __ ] rave
all this stuff was going on and and and
i was like
this is the coolest [ __ ] thing i just
have to keep doing more and more drugs
yeah that's the problem see this is what
i love about ramdas
one of my teachers is he you know ramdas
you've heard of him this guy
you know it rings a bell he was he was
so he was hanging out with tim leary
at harvard and they were the professors
they got kicked out of harvard because
they were
like uh taking lsd and giving lsd to the
students
and because they were interested from at
first because they were both like
really brilliant uh psychologists they
did
and this was a new substance and they
thought they had sort of
like discovered what was going to be the
next phase of uh
human evolution or a nootropic that was
going to like completely accelerate the
civilization uh they get kicked out of
harvard
at the time ronda's name was richard
alpert and so they're like
exactly where any any of us have been
where it's where we're running into this
seemingly like built into the matrix
inhibition thing that they
uh that currently what do they call it
tolerance
and so so they're literally drinking lsd
like sandoz laboratory 1960s lsd
out of vials like liquid lsd drinking it
because i didn't even know
i've been droppers because i didn't
drive i did a dropper
sipping it out of like [ __ ] yes
i'm naughty look it's crazy there's a
harvard psychedelic club yeah because
you know they're
on acid you do get a tolerance really
fast yeah but
they were running into the same problem
and so
the reason so albert goes to india with
a like [ __ ] ton of acid
that owls lee you know you know you've
ever heard of owlsley that bear he's
like the dancing bears on the
grateful dead that that's owesly's
nickname he was the
lsd chemist of the dead like steely dan
kid charlemagne it's a whole song
written about him it's it's you know
he's as famous
i know someone who went with him
delivering acid in san francisco and
said
these [ __ ] hippies they'd come out of
their house and they
they call it pranayama i think pranayam
they fully bow prostrating to it
you know like which is why there's a
line in the steely dance song which is
like
did you feel like jesus you know because
he was like blowing over his mind anyway
he makes a special batch for
albert who takes it to india to give to
people who've been meditating
for you know their whole lives and ask
them what the [ __ ] is this
and you know some people loved it some
people
said this is a waste of time but he
meets his guru
this is one of the famous crazy [ __ ]
stories um
and his guru says to him like you have
something you want to give me
give it to me what do you have and so he
gives him this [ __ ]
powerful acid to this old man in a
blanket
who eats it and no reaction
nothing happens he gives them like a fl
something for us that for me
that's fetal position like 500
micrograms like you know
that's weeping fetal position what have
i done i'm never coming down
no response no reaction albert gets back
to the united states is telling his
psychologist friends this
story they're like he got swindled he
pawned
he put into palmed it you know he
obviously didn't [ __ ] eat
no one's eating 500 micrograms of lsd
and having zero reaction
physiologically impossible so the next
time
he's with this guy neem crowley baba was
his name he says to him
the last time you were here did you give
me something
and he said yeah because this guy was
telepathic and there's no other way to
put it and he goes
what did you give me what did you give
me and he said
lsd and he said did i eat it do you
think i really ate it because he knows
he's thinking he didn't really eat it
and he's like give me more give me more
so he gives him a massive
doom dose like i don't know how many
capsules these are capsules of this
stuff
what does the capsule look like i mean
like you know when you get the
uh it's in you know like a pill
you know like a died pill is the
substrate that shits in
so he's like he's holding in his hand
taking one
chewing it taking the other chewing it
taking the other chewing it then he
opens his mouth so he sees like his
tongue
is just covered in like glue and and
then
he like and i now i know people who saw
this from the other perspective because
ramdas told this story a bunch it's a
cool story
but basically he like goes under his
blanket and he starts
shaking like he's having a seizure
moaning like
an is like oh [ __ ] i just basically just
killed an old indian
like i just i just killed him i killed
him
i broke an old indian man he was like
trying to like
flex on me or something and then and so
then uh
after doing this for a little while and
i know people who saw ron doss he was
like about to cry
face pale probably thinking about
lawsuits part thing about like
how the indian authorities might arrest
me for this [ __ ] like
uh and then he like comes out of his
blanket
and he's like smiling come goes about
his business completely fine you're just
[ __ ] with me you're just [ __ ] with
him like
is this what you wanted me to do is this
like what you were hoping
for for did you want to see something
like that but anyway he says to him at
the end of this day
he says to him we used to have something
like this in the indus
valley uh he said this will bring you
into the presence of
christ but the problem is you can't stay
there with this
and it was like just the most brilliant
articulation of the problem with these
substances which is like
it's affirming what we all already know
holy [ __ ]
it's showing me what's inside the ark of
the covenant like i'm seeing
past the veil and it's real whether or
not sober people or people have never
tripped want to believe that what can we
do but it's real it's something you're
seeing something more than just
like mashing your brain but
also you can't [ __ ] stay there
because it's like
we're in school here we gotta go to
school here right now like that's what
we're doing here you don't get to
play hooky too much it's like built in
to not
it doesn't work out do you think that
like we've we've had past lives and that
we've spiritually evolved to this point
or do you think like this is something
that we get one life and then
i mean come on dude that's that's a
rookie question of course we've
had thousands of lives yeah and let me
tell you about a rookie move that you
might be pulling without even realizing
it
paying full price for your netflix
subscription
but only accessing a fraction of the
content that they
actually offer how does that happen well
based on your ip address netflix will
serve you
domestic programming if you're in
america you get the us
content but when you run out of stuff
that you want to watch
what do you do you get expressvpn
and now all of a sudden you can change
your ip address to any of
90 different countries that they offer
and when you do that
boom you're now magically accessing
all kinds of great content that netflix
is only serving
to other countries it makes you get a
whole lot
more value for your netflix subscription
and all your other streaming platforms
for that matter
now i'm gonna offer you an extra three
months
of expressvpn for free
how do you get it you go to
expressvpn.com stevo
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com slash stevo you get a one-year
subscription
and now call that a year in three months
thanks to me yeah dude so go to
expressvpn.com
stevo sign up and get privacy when
you're served from the web
and 90 different countries to be in to
get all kinds of extra content
yeah dude thank me later don't be a
rookie get expressvpn
now but not a lot of people think that
yeah i don't know
i don't know if i believe that here's
the thing there's so much
irrefutable proof of reincarnation
that it's kind of laughable for anybody
to not
believe in it would you agree i love you
how sweet is that you're like no this is
proven you're like carl sagan over there
no we've got the charts i mean obviously
i do believe in it
and like i have a method for
understanding it
just based on my own like various
incarnations in my own life you know
like if you look back at all the phases
you've been through and you know every
single one you've gone through so many
[ __ ] faces for sure
like i went through like a like a mild
smith's face i was wearing like
[ __ ] you know what i mean but to me it
was real
that was almost like a different life
for like you know when i was in high
school certainly
my concerns were so different from now
and also like my physical
form so when you look at like just the
for you forget like before
we're born and after we die if you just
look at the general human existence
there's so many lives in any human life
sure i mean
people are reincarnating all the [ __ ]
time right and so i think
that you know i i whether or not this
there's some continuance i think there
is
i know it's not i don't imagine it to be
provable i agree with what's the proof
you're talking about i mean just like
like the people who
particularly when they're babies they'll
just like say weird [ __ ] and then
they'll check it
and you know and yeah there's that like
four-year-old that like
yeah and predicted her past death and
they found the blaze
right like like little kids will be
looking at pictures and they'll be like
oh well that's when when i was doing
this
they're looking at the picture like a
dead grandfather and then everything
they say checks out
so yeah full disclosure i mean i agree
with you duncan i was just trying to get
the click bait
you know duncan trussell talks about
past lives you know i mean
right actually look really you're like
the mocker valley of podcast
that's awesome man wow here's the
problem with uh reincarnation i think
it's
it's it's a a great number of people are
tripped up over this
because of religion well no it's there's
a numbers
problem with it you know like if we are
reincarnated
then how do you how do you factor in
the ever-growing population ourselves
i solved this are some souls new or some
souls recycled
and then yeah i think uh sure i think
that
when you factor in all the dimensions
that we're not privy to
and then when you factor in the fact
that even like a
a fleeting thought is is essentially a
life
you know like there is such
you guys are like kindred spirits dude
and then when you bring into it like the
crazy [ __ ] quantum
physics [ __ ] where it's like every
single possible
outcome of every single possible
situation is all simultaneously
happening and there is no such thing as
right now and all is right now like
then it gets really crazy and you don't
have to worry about the numbers game
anymore
then it works yeah yeah that is a that
is a valid
also um god man this is like a
one of my one of the only times i really
broke through on dmt
at burning man i like did the thing and
went into the thing that everyone talks
about and i was in the [ __ ] thing and
you know but i had this
sense of like oh i could like completely
like obliviate myself here
somehow merge with the universe
obviously not true i've never heard of
anyone dying
on dmt but that dmt not a voice but
you know whatever it is said oh you can
always go
back you can always go back to that
moment if you want
and then i ever since then i sort of
re-uh
revised my idea of reincarnation being a
thing that starts
with your birth and ends with your death
and and now i see
it more as like uh probably upon like
dropping your body or
as they call it in the east you might be
able to like actually
choose frames of your incarnation that
you want to jump back into
and start your life there meaning that
any given moment
like future versions of you are sort of
pouring into the current
version of you just to experience life
from this point going forward but you
would never know that because it's you
and they just
sort of resonate with you i mean i think
that the primitive idea of reincarnation
is that you die and you're you get a
break that's a funny one like a lot of
new agers have this spa
theory where you [ __ ] get hit by a
car and suddenly you're like floating in
like
some you know hyper dimensional spa
water like i think next
the next life i want to be paralyzed for
the neck down that would be
awesome sure it's really the blueberry
i'm sorry i what it what if it does it's
not like that what if it's just you die
and you open your eyes and you're like
in your 40s
going through a divorce there's no space
there's no rest
there's no anything and you do you just
have a little deja vu or like what the
[ __ ] was that
sure what happened was you just came
back in into a new life
full with full amnesia of what you used
to be sure
is a big deal and i have no problem with
any of that i want to run by
run by you two things and then i want
you to tell me if you think
uh i'm a genius or if this is just
completely idiotic
but what if i already think you're a
genius okay good
i i i really think i've i kind of
figured something out with this because
the idea of like uh
how did it all begin it's just a stupid
question right there was big bang all
right well what banged
you know like okay then you come up with
something that banged all right well
where did that thing come from you know
you keep going back and like
so the concept of linear time is
clearly a flawed idea right and i
i at one point i was smoking some pot i
was writing an email and i
i felt like i figured it out i said you
know there was a time
when humans thought the world was flat
and
and they were actually terrified to get
in their boats and go too far because
they were legitimately scared that their
boat
would fall off the end of the world and
that they would perish
so then i just equated that i said you
know like
i believe we will come to a point where
it is seemingly
it is equal right equally ridiculous to
think of
time as flat such that there's a
beginning or an end that you could fall
off of
when in fact just like the world
time is round dude you know it's a cycle
and uh i mean and if you think of it
that way then what was before that what
was before that was
nothing was before that because it's a
[ __ ] cycle it's round it doesn't
begin
or end and that's one that was one
little sort of
thought that i had that i was pretty
proud of now i've got one more
which is that the idea of of the body
and death now we've heard the saying
that we're not uh human beings having a
spiritual experience but rather we're
spiritual beings having a human
experience
now to give the the idea of like when we
die
we awaken to eternal life you know that
actually we're
eternal you know and and all of this um
i i like and especially because we're
multi-dimensional beings
so like like we absolutely exist in all
of these we're just not aware of it
because
when we incarnate in this physical body
we kind of make a deal
that we forget that we're spirits so we
don't know what the [ __ ] going on and
we certainly do wake up at the moment of
death
but now to look at death and and what it
really represents
the theory that i came up with was to
imagine that
that the soul so to speak is like uh
uh a [ __ ] uh like a radio wave
kind of a deal the body the body is
essentially
uh like a radio that picks up that uh
you know
now the the i think that the flaw in our
view of the human brain is that the the
human brain
the human body is a generator
of consciousness you know like a
transmitter
it generates the consciousness like yeah
you know
like uh like said like a a transmitter
would
but i don't see it that way i see the
the i see the
the human body the brain as a receiver
of the signal which is out there so now
you to make it a metaphor you could take
a radio that's like dialed in
to like a certain station like 106.7
right now you can take that [ __ ]
physical radio
and you can take a sledgehammer to it
you can smash it you can smack it you
can destroy it destroy that body
into oblivion but you have done nothing
to
interrupt or kill the signal so what we
are is that we're the
we're the the receiver of the signal you
know we're the receiver the signal you
can shoot yourself in the head you can
all you're doing is killing the radio
you're not [ __ ] with the signal man
and the signal is forever dude and
on top of that there's so many stations
dude there's
limit and you can plug that station into
a different [ __ ] radio later on down
the line and there's your reincarnation
and [ __ ]
yeah i love it yeah i i thought about
this the receiver idea
it's particularly wrapped around like uh
you know when you meet someone who's all
puffed up and [ __ ]
and it's like uh
it's a quality of confusion i think you
know it's like a
if there were a sentient radio and it
was playing
the beatles it would be easy for the
radio to be like i'm [ __ ] amazed
totally yeah so i think people get a
little confused regarding their identity
uh in that regard i'll do that that's
another great layer on top
that just takes another step further i
[ __ ] love that
it's entanglement is what they call it
you know we're entangled in this
situation and um yeah and like
in buddhism it's uh this is sort of the
map of
how to sort of predict what your next
life is going to be
what they say is well look at what
you're doing now and that'll get you
give you some idea of where you're
headed
and it's because it's momentum based
essentially so it's like
whatever this particular frequency is it
has this kind of momentum to it the
momentum is karma
and so that momentum has been going on
for
you know millennia in calcul this was
actually one of my like
ketamine visions was i was seeing my
past lives
i couldn't specifically see him but i i
knew somehow like what i was looking at
was all my past lives
and there was so many of them and they
look like fish eggs kind of floating in
space just all these
ways my karma had expressed itself but
yeah it's like so this is why there is
uh
this emphasis on meditation uh and
people get confused about the statement
meditation is the pr
you know preparation for death and what
what it means is like
there is an acknowledgement of exactly
what you're saying
the body is finite but there's this sort
of
um transmission that is your soul
that's never gonna stop and so when you
die
it's it's i mean just have you ever met
like a healthy i mean unless you're like
lucky and you just get hit you're like
jogging in a marathon get hit by a
[ __ ] car or something you know
probably you get sick when people are
dying they get really sick and confused
usually they're in a lot of pain then
they start taking the morphine
then they sort of like and you've seen
someone die it's nuts because they like
literally they lift off of that thing
you're talking about like
it's like watching an airplane take off
only it's taking off from the time from
time
not you know not the earth and so they
they're spiraling through like they're
they're talking to their mom and then
they're talking to like you know
somebody that they knew and they're you
know you have no idea who they're
talking to
but it's because they're spiraling
through time because they're breaking
free
but um you know but yeah but the uh
the momentum so so the idea here is like
you want to die
with some tranquility and some peace
because if you can't if you can handle
it which
is something like some of these tibetan
llamas they describe it as
like being in a snowstorm it's so
confusing so if you can maintain
some some element of being calm then
there is a possibility
of at the very least like having a
little bit more control over what your
next
life might be instead of it being like
what it is for what
what it what it is for a lot of people
which is like terrifying
and the description is like suddenly you
don't have a body you've had a body all
this [ __ ] time
and it's like what the [ __ ] i need a
body because that's what you're familiar
with
and then you you kind of you you you
impatiently race
into your next into your parents which
by the way
which is something really cool in the
tibetan book of the dead which is what
they read to like
monks who've died to guide them into the
next life
you know the idea is you see all these
people [ __ ] not to go back to bang
bus or anything
but it's like you literally see a field
within which there's
all these people [ __ ] and it's
weirdly like
it's like porn it's like the one that
turns you on the most
you you go to that so basically you were
watching your parents [ __ ] and you're
like that's [ __ ]
hot i want to get in on that and you
like go into that and then the next
thing you know you're
their kid and this is the wow this is
and this is why in this life we're so
into sex and [ __ ] and all that
because it's like that
same momentum that brought us here you
know continues it's all momentum
it's really fascinating it's a really
fascinating take on what happens when
you die
it's crazy god over here is just
straight
addicted to youtube videos about people
uh near-death experiences and like
experiences their experiences would
happen when they die
and i've been fascinated with that and
it's it's weird because
in the near-death experience is sort of
community and
and all of these people telling their
stories about it there's a lot of common
ground man you know you
really like there's a lot that adds up
and and it becomes credible because
everyone's describing the same thing
i've never heard about the watching
people [ __ ] part
but like i've heard about like um
they talk about a spirit guide you know
comes and and and you feel compelled
that you want to like uh
go with it go and go with your family
they say go with your spirit guide you
know like go and go with your spirit
guide
it's also really fascinating how like
the life review
yeah the life review dude where you can
like i mean dude there's like are we are
we uh
agreed that life review is like we
we can just call that a fact because
like that all of the accounts of it are
all so
like well have you ever had like have
you guys ever had like a life review
in the drug experience where you go
through like different situations
because like in the
in the near death experience people have
these life reviews and they're
like feeling how they the person felt
that you talk [ __ ] to you and like
everything but but i want to bring that
up because like um i'm so fascinated
with your fascination with life reviews
like dude life review is the most
crucial thing if anybody hasn't heard
this term you can look it up what it is
is that like
at the at the moment of death like you
know
they say it in rock songs or whatever
poems like your life flashes before your
eyes
now that's saying about your when you
die your life flashes before your eyes
like the as it's described in people who
have had the experience and that like
died had their life review and then come
back
and and like yeah they're completely
changed because they're like [ __ ] i've
caused that much damage
you experience your entire life like you
could say your life flashes before your
eyes it happens in a moment but it
also happens in super slow-mo like
time's just not even
you you you re-experience your entire
life
in this flash with like super
consciousness like the consciousness of
of like the like the whole like
basically god if
even if you don't like that term but
like you go through your whole life
and you personally experience from the
perspective of
every thing that you had an influence
over
and with the detail of that if there is
a mosquito
like off like uh you know
further than the eye can see like you
have the experience of being that
mosquito like
the idea of oneness becomes an
experience where you actually
like you're no longer separated so you
you review your whole life
and you and it's not for the purpose of
punishing you
for like the harm that you've done to
others it's just for for the experience
so it becomes real like oh my god
and the the common denominator in having
this life review is that everybody who
comes back
to to being human everyone who comes
back to life
now they are so overwhelmingly concerned
with not [ __ ] over other people they
are no longer concerned with material
things like they are like
totally changed and in such a way and
like
i've seen so many like uh just been so
fascinated with this life if you think
that i've like to think i don't even
need to have a life review to just
trust that's the truth and just do not
[ __ ] with other people be
generous well it's crazy up your messes
you know like
it's crazy because the two common
denominators that people have i mean
like thousands and thousands of people
like 90 of them come back and get a
divorce and then the
other ones come back and and they can't
wear watches because watches don't work
what yeah i never heard them i mean
watches don't hurt like
they can't wear watch because it always
breaks holy [ __ ] we've added another
[ __ ] part of that roller coaster
we're talking about in the beginning
like before the divorce we
put him under like we kill him and then
bring him back to life
i mean dude and like there's a really
good example of a guy who had a
near-death experience
and there's a documentary about it is
that the one called
i am but um the dude who
who directed all the like just
monstrously successful jim carrey movies
uh tom shadiak yeah yeah this guy
was like private jets like [ __ ] look
at my
[ __ ] huge mansion this guy was just
so tens of millions of dollars for like
every movie he was just cranking him out
so he just had obnoxious amounts of
money
then at some point he was riding uh
his bicycle had like a hellacious
wipeout riding his bicycle
and and in that wipeout like had like
where he
like he died had the near-death
experience came back from it
and the dude ever since
i gave every i don't even gave
everything away but like
lives in a [ __ ] trailer in a trailer
park in malibu like just doesn't
has no [ __ ] interest whatsoever in uh
like the lifestyle that he had like he's
a good example of like
how near-death experiences like uh
change people
you know and i volunteered at a hospice
called rose room hospice in
la for a little bit and the guy who was
like came to tell us how to like be with
dying people
he was one of those people he had a [ __ ]
ton of money
he [ __ ] died he went the whole thing
the life review the whole thing didn't
want to come back
didn't that's the other commonality no
thanks i'm done it's like no you're not
done
you're going back and you go back and
you and like um it's painful going back
into the body
yes well he what he said is
what's over there
makes this where we're at seem like
death
compared to that other place like we're
in a he
i think he called it a warp like he said
we're in a time warp
when you're alive and the other side is
so wonderful
it's more of the spa theory of things i
hope that's the case
i really do i i want that to be the
the the reality versus like the other
versions of it
which have justice built into them you
know
a kind of like like mathematical justice
and maybe the life review is enough
maybe if you do the life review yeah
and and that is the penance it's like
experiencing the
right way that you may ever feel
yeah yeah and that's all you need that's
the purification or something
but um yeah i don't i mean it's so
mysterious but i do
think it's like pretty incredible the
way that regardless of culture
regardless of what your religious
background is
you're gonna have the same experience
when you die that's one of the things
the nde experts talk about
is it's like it doesn't matter if you're
hindu jewish whatever it may be
the that's the life review it's the
light
it's all the things that you hear about
and it seems to transcend culture
which is another implication that you
know it's uh
it's something real or if not real the
cynical version of it as well it's uh
something built into us it's crazy like
you hear like a life
or like a near-death experience story of
um like a 60 year old woman that goes to
church every day you know and
she she dies and comes back and they're
like well are you still a christian
she's like
no not at all like it has nothing to do
with that you know and then
you know just hearing hearing that from
that perspective you're like [ __ ] man
like there's something out there you
know yeah i mean it's more there's
something
in here you know like the the idea of
space and time
is just such an illusion um but but yeah
yeah the
the the documentary that i did the whole
thing was like i went to india to go
meditate to go
find like this thing i'm seeking and
like i read this thing from emerson that
said you know nate
quasi varus extra and and it doesn't
really tell you what that is and i
looked it up and it was uh it's latin
for do not seek outside yourself
and i just had that app it's like you
didn't have to go 15 000 miles to india
to find any answers like you could just
do it from
the wild ride van you know or just kind
of sure well that's the classic
archetype
like you had it in you all along you
know like uh we're drawn to those kinds
of stories
yeah yeah it's also like we can't have
this spiritual [ __ ] tourism right now
i mean it's like
to me like the ironic thing about
spiritual tourism when you're doing the
thing you get in the plane you fly to
wherever you think the holy people are
going to the amazon to take ayahuasca is
like as you're flying over the amazon
you're just like
dumping jet fuel on top of the place
where you're gonna go after spiritual
experience that's so funny
so we yeah i think that's a a real great
epiphany you had because uh
it's it just i especially these days i
don't know that i think there's some
there's a bit of an illusion
in all of that that being said if ramdas
didn't
go to india with a bunch of acid i think
i wouldn't be as happy a person now
because he you know because of his
experiences there but maybe the idea is
they already did that so now we don't
have we don't have to do it you know we
the data's out there right we're ready
for you
if you want to sort of uh you know pick
up some path or discipline
do you have i just have to say that like
your
comment that it would be easy for the
radio
which is simply transmitting or
receiving a signal of the beatles to be
like dude i'm [ __ ] red
yeah it's like dude the radio getting
all proud of itself for the signal it's
picking
thinking it's the beatles the radio
thinks it's the beatles
they've taken credit and then next is
led zeppelin
down the street i [ __ ] do that that's
my favorite thing
and and uh as as far as to like the
commonality of
all the the life review and all these
experiences like i think that i do want
to give some credit
to i believe every like
religious writing every like
spiritual way of life for even though
like
it's all so perverted and and you know
like just messed up over time
i think there's a common ground in in
all of it in that the concept of oneness
you know that god is omnipresent that we
are all like sort of different
expressions of the divine yeah and that
separation is an illusion
you know and i try to explain this to
people
like and and i can't maybe you can help
me figure it out and i got this
from uh neil donald walsh i'm a huge fan
of the conversations with god book
series
oh [ __ ] i gotta okay that's the last
straw man i'm gonna put this on my list
i've heard about this book so many times
i haven't read it yet
try pcp
god got it your conversations with god
and and all
like uh it is it was a big [ __ ] deal
for me you know like
uh i i don't talk about it too much but
my mom
in uh 1998 suffered a an
aneurysm where like she had like a
capillary like burst
and brain hemorrhages subarachnoid brain
hemorrhage and
it was like almost like the most tragic
thing about it was that she survived
because she was like
heinously disabled both mentally and
physical
and uh and on top of that she got bed
sores and and
then and bed sores are the the worst
[ __ ] thing i think they they happen
to defenseless
[ __ ] people who are helpless and
they're the most
like like my mom and she survived for
five years
and i like the reason i don't talk about
it a lot is because i just don't like to
bump people out but but my mom
cried you know she cried she when my mom
said my bottom
like like uh it was it was so hard for
me i developed i got it i got really
angry i got really angry at any god
that could allow for that experience you
know
like [ __ ] whatever god let that [ __ ]
happen you know and you can
this is my personal take on it you could
be like oh [ __ ] any god that let the
holocaust happen you could like
the the world is is rife with with
examples
of like if you want to be mad at god you
know
but now here's what where conversations
with god really helped me a lot
was that the the the premise of it is
that
god is everything you know god said but
god has one
singular unit which is what we would
refer to as god
in the absolute the realm of the
absolute
is devoid of experience because they're
there's only
like the one thing so you know that's
why we call it a relationship
you have to have separate things for one
thing
to relate to another thing that is the
realm of the relative
and so god as the absolute is perfection
is pure love but without any experience
of such
so god in the absolute and this would be
creation
has to divide itself into
separate things such that there can be
experience
which stems from relativity one thing
relating to another
and it is in that division where god
divides itself
into separate things for the purpose of
experience so
the premise of conversations with god is
that all of creation
all of us everything that exists in the
realm of the relative
is specifically an exercise
in god experiencing itself
and and and by that view then now i can
look at
it like my anger at god was based on a
flawed premise
that god was somehow over here and
allowed this terrible thing to happen to
my mom
who was over there whereas like in the
the idea that this is how people react
to
wendy's like i'm outta here
but the idea that like the idea that
it's not god was over there and mom
but mom was an expression of god you
know and and it's not up to me to
understand why
mom's experience was valuable on any
level i mean to be fair it was also a
natural cause of a natural law of cause
and effect
mom didn't take care of herself very
well you know you can't chalk everything
up to cause and effect because a lot of
bad things happen
but the idea that god mom was god god
wasn't over there letting it happen
you know like god mom was god god had
that experience
god didn't leave her out there you know
but we're all god
and and and and the idea that god
divides itself
into all these separate things so that
it can have the experience of itself
then now the sudden i'm i by adopting
that theory
i look at you i look at everyone i look
at the guy who [ __ ] cut me off in
traffic and
and i gotta remember oh yeah we we are
god divided we're all
equally divine and it's gonna come out
in the life review
it's gonna come out in the live review
that like it all comes back together and
now
we actually have the experience as as
god of all the [ __ ] we did
so if i so anything i do to you i'm
doing to myself
anything and like that makes us all
equal there's no better or worse we're
all god and
and then if you can just adopt that
theory which i which i took from
conversations with god
now that just there is no room for
hatred there is no room for
selfishness there is it just doesn't
allow because we're all god
you know what rondas cause he says we're
all god and drag
and it's a cool way to put it but like
the here's a here's a i
like i love there's a form of yoga
called bhakti yoga
it's what the hare krishnas do but
they're only one example of it and
what's really interesting about it is
it's a breakdown of like
exactly what you're saying and in in you
know the
detailed way that only like 5 000 years
of thinking about this concept could
could
bring you know and so there's a name for
it of course the name and i think i'm
mispronouncing it but it's something
like a cincasinka beta tatfa
which means simultaneous oneness and
difference so
that's the description of krishna and
then
what's really cool about it and not to
say
okay now you you all have permission to
be an [ __ ] or whatever but what's
really cool about it is that
any relationship with god is
going to evolve you over time so
in other words if you are truly angry at
god
because that is a connection to the
divine
via anger and because the divine
krishna is the source of all love or the
reservoir of pleasure there's so many
beautiful names to describe
um to describe krishna
because that's what you're connecting
through to with anger
that's going to start coming into you
through the anger so the anger you get
which is why the more the more your
connection to that
grows so in the mythology the worst
demons
who are trying to destroy krishna out of
just you know various forms of rage or
anger
some of them may be justified maybe not
they end up becoming the great disciples
they
they end up becoming the the the like
true like best friends and associates of
god because oh my god donald trump
is the the coming of jesus
he's an incarnation of them they were
right
the heavy duty because the problem is
like you know
anybody who's getting the thoughts
you're getting is it's wonderful because
it means that you're you're on you're on
the way
you're on the path and it's beautiful a
lot of people they don't have these
thoughts like they're in in the
description you were giving earlier
about the various entities you encounter
in the
uh uh astral realm uh
is is in the bhagavad-gita they break it
down
about you know that there's i think
there's an entire chapter dedicated to
what is a demon what's a demonic
personality
and the description is very true it's
very sad
it's a it because what's happened is
someone is completely
got is completely ignorant of what where
happiness comes from so
whenever you run into someone like the
person you're mentioning you
died and suddenly is living in a trailer
uh
pre-living in the trailer they've gotten
confused they think the material stuff
is gonna satisfy them
[ __ ] it's like exactly your
experience when you find yourself like
okay
if i do the right amount of blow nitrous
oxide yeah
get all these things simultaneously to
happen then freedom
and it's really sad it creates a
feedback loop you know and and so
people like potentially donald trump or
anybody who's become so consumed
in that themselves as the radio um
it's a never-ending terrible cycle that
they go through
it it's almost like some horrific
groundhog day
and so which is where the the compassion
for them comes in because it's like
[ __ ] you're you're like you're wasting
the whole thing
like you've you're pretending the gross
depiction that it gives is like imagine
a dog
that is so diseased all its teeth have
fallen out
it's found a dry bone on the street it's
chewing on the dry bone
and because it has no teeth its gums are
getting cut up by the dry bone
but it's happy because it thinks that
the its own blood is
coming from meat on the bone so it's
it's it's actually like
drinking its own blood i mean like oh
what a juicy bone
this is the predicament a lot of people
get into which is why you know
anytime that's a weird you know very
cliche experience
probably everyone here has had where you
run into someone who seemingly has it
all
and they're the most wretched desperate
depressed thing that you've ever run
into and it's like you you don't even
know how to
help them because you know that they're
so fixated on the next
you know what's around the corner like
okay well it didn't work to have the
mansion
in the yacht and then the other yacht
and then the jet and i [ __ ]
so many people don't even escape from
[ __ ]
you know people are like getting like
weird bruce lee bodies and they just
[ __ ] it's from [ __ ]
but it's not working you know that's a
problem it's not working
empty inside they're humping a leg
they're humping a cosmic leg it's like
it's just as pathetic as watching a
horny dog
let me throw this at you um you know
like the idea of the
materialism doesn't work and everything
and i think that like but before i got
sober
like i had no confidence that i was
gonna i was
i was certain that i was gonna die young
like
go out in flames like it was just a
matter of time and that and and
what made me cool was that i was
resigned to that
so i didn't care about about making
smart business decisions i didn't care
about
about if i had like knew what was what
was going on with the bank account i
didn't give a [ __ ] about
getting screwed over in contracts
because i was in this
i wasn't going to live forever but i was
going to be remembered forever because i
was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] in radio you
know
and uh then i got clean and sober
you know and and all of a sudden started
taking care of myself now
like like in sort of early sobriety it's
like okay
so now i'm actually did make it past 30
years old
and now i'm taking care of myself and
[ __ ] now i might actually live
for like now i might not even be halfway
through my [ __ ] life
yeah like oh [ __ ] is that scary like i
think that
death is super easy you know death has
to be easy otherwise like
you know like we don't have much to look
forward to that we got death has got to
be cool
it's living it's hard man and and like i
all of a sudden i'm like i'm not
i'm still not really afraid of death i'm
afraid of the [ __ ] i'd like oh my god
i've got all this living to do
so now like i gotta actually get clever
about business
now i gotta actually save up because
like what i don't wanna you know
and on top of that i'm gonna i'm through
and through i'm an attention [ __ ] man
and like and and nobody wants to
contemplate
let alone like really like ponder or
they're really like
like i would like uh getting you know
obsessed with the idea of uh
mortality right like people just don't
in the east
totally easy old people are cool take
care of them but in the west
like well like you mentioned hospice
probably a lot of [ __ ] people
in in in the west don't even know the
definition of a word hospice
right because they don't even [ __ ]
want to know like they don't want to
think about they got their [ __ ]
blinders on like
la i don't even [ __ ] think about
dying
like not going to happen and i don't
want to look at an old people because
to be old is a [ __ ] party foul you're
reminding me of my mortality and that's
not cool
so so being old is a party fail
and and and to be an old attention [ __ ]
is the scariest [ __ ] you know to be
an addict
to absolutely to have an overdeveloped
need for
for attention as an old [ __ ]
wrinkly old person is the scariest
proposition i could possibly [ __ ]
imagine
and that's where like sobriety for me
represented okay i need to
to like have some some separation
between my persona like i ca
i can't identify with like stevo or the
personality i gotta have some
like build an identity as just who i am
and relationships what really matters
but my question is what i'm getting to
you with
is that it's such i thought i
intellectually philosophically i
absolutely subscribed to the idea of
material things don't work like you know
but then again at the same time
like i'm i'm a hustler man i'm a hustler
and i'm trying to [ __ ]
run as many businesses as i can i'm
trying to like
i'm i'm looking for businesses which
specifically represent
a way out of the attention [ __ ]
business so that i can be an old person
and not worry about where the
[ __ ] next meal is coming from right
so like so it's such
you know like and i got my daily
meditation dude i do uh
mantra based meditation like i make sure
i average
41 minutes every day like wow twenty
yeah i've done it for
dude like a few days ago like my little
thing go ahead and show the camera dude
all right
i know you want to do that like i'll
show you where i'm at
i have meditated for 535
straight days averaging 41 minutes
and since december 27th of 2019
i have spent 366 hours and 38 minutes
meditating
amazing i don't like transcend really
too much but the fact that i actually
have the discipline to sit
to sit still and quiet and and try
i think it's like it's a big deal you
know and
i i attribute like uh how well my life
is going now with
my disciplined meditation practice when
he goes to gelson's he's floating two
feet above the ground
but but i mean besides but i get the
daily meditation i really am
like i'm devout about about
you know being vigilant and disciplined
in my meditation practice
and and i i really really believe that
this meditation practice
and the regularity of it never missing
twice a day that i've i believe
and i know this is like [ __ ] kind of
a weird thing to say but i believe it
brings about
a relationship with the universe such
that the universe conspires in my favor
call me a freak but i don't care because
i i [ __ ] hang on to that
and i [ __ ] ride with it and i really
feel like i benefit from it
but at the same time i can read every
spiritual reading about how like it's
not the material things
and i'm like okay but i'm gonna [ __ ]
hustle i'm gonna try to make as much
money as i can
so that i don't have to worry about [ __ ]
there's a funny verse in the
bhagavad-gita
where christians describing the people
that come to christ come to him
and one of the descriptions is the
seekers after gold
and it because it's because if you're if
we're going to start working with the
idea
that every single thing around you is an
expression of
the divine then suddenly the whole like
sacred and profane idea it goes out the
window like now we're just dealing with
various forms of energy and our own
karmic
attraction to this this form or that
form
and so what ends up happening is people
get confused like i've you know people
especially at buddhism they start
thinking it's some sort of passive
thing where you sort of hang everything
up and then you're just sitting around
and your whole life becomes sort of like
a mistake or everything you wanted and
all that stuff was like an immature
thing
i think this is a misconception
uh because because i really think like
the invitation is is not to like give up
your life the invitation is live your
life as you
but really live it you know because if
when you look back
at the unconscious way you were living
uh i think many people would think you
were [ __ ] very ambitious even though
if you're
a nihilist or whatever you're very
ambitious but whenever i look back at
like unconscious periods it doesn't none
of it mattered
like i wasn't there anyway so the idea
is like you can be
in your own life and and one of my
friends
i remember like very sympathetically put
his hand on my shoulder he's like you
know you just have to burn off all the
karma
there's no way out of it meaning all
those desires all those things you want
all that stuff it's like you still have
that
and it's still your soul wanting to
express itself into the into the
universe
but now the ideas do it mindfully you
know it's
there's a big difference but my
meditation teacher tells me like
here's how you drink when you're
drinking the moment
you aren't aware that you're drinking
anymore stop drinking for the night
you know that that's that's one way to
do it meaning like
and you know and if you do if you try
that it's impossible if you're like us
which is like three four sips i'm not
doing [ __ ] mindful drinking because
the demon
is coming to me and now it's like i want
more moscow mules
i don't even know why but there is a way
i think there is all i'm saying is
don't be hard on yourself because [ __ ]
man you're absolutely right
and also if you read some of the ray
kurzweil [ __ ] watch out
your the whole life span the whole human
lifespan might be
like a lot more than we even think right
now if you know and
it would be a decision based thing but
you think you're
now you're thinking like i'm going to
kick the bucket when i'm 80 or whatever
i don't know it's that's the scariest
idea what if it's 160
what are the 200 what if it's 500 yeah
you're only 5
of the way there yeah yeah exactly so i
do think that and
also the contemplation of death is uh
as i've been taught like very important
and and some people say
carry death on your shoulder 100 very
dead yeah
100 to dude to live to live with your
blinders on pretending today i don't
want to think about i'm going to die and
we're just going to pretend that that's
not a thing
then all of a sudden it's like oh wait a
second i could have
made that like a of the forefront of my
consciousness and deliberately
to be deliberate about living the life
you want to have
have lived when it's over you know like
you got initiated it seems like into
like you some people you know you and i
i'm sure you have friends who are
bitching about their mom or whatever
sometimes and you and i when they we
hear that there's a at least there's a
piece of me that's like
must be nice to be pissed off at your
[ __ ] mom you know because like
it once your mom's gone that's that's it
my friend put it the best ways like it's
like the salt goes out of your soup
forever
or like doug stanhope talks about
i heard him say something like there's
no one to call and [ __ ] brag to about
[ __ ]
like the way you came with your mom it's
just gone it's gone
and so but that's impermanence and when
we lose our parents
and especially the way you lost your
your your mom uh
my mom got diagnosed with cancer and
then died over about four years
but i had four good years with her
knowing she was gonna die but what
happened to you was
was uh and so many other people just one
day
for whatever reason that vain
vocabulary burst and that's the end of
your experience with your mom
as you knew her for your entire life
gone
forever and this is the re
this is the human reality this is what
it's like to be alive
and it's i i compare it to the blinders
i think of it as like
we've all been thrown out of a [ __ ]
plane we're plummeting towards the
[ __ ] ground
full speed ahead into god knows [ __ ]
what and a lot of us
you know we've like set a nice dinner
table and we're like
eating and talking and anytime someone's
like hey aren't we fault
falling into the boy and they're like
shut the [ __ ] up
eat your [ __ ] mashed potatoes
oh my god dude and we can do this
forever man i want what a joy
what a [ __ ] joy i remember you i
really have enjoyed this
and uh of course i'm in my head thinking
like or is it like
did i [ __ ] just shut the [ __ ] up and
not talk so much
i loved every second of it man no no no
this whole thing is like you know it's
because you know the other thing about
the radio problem is like yeah puffed up
radio thinks he's the [ __ ] beatles
there's a lot of radios that like think
they're the opposite of the beatles you
know
it's more likely you know that people
are like really artificial dude
i'm just straight static man i can't
even pick up
you got like dude the the netflix things
going strong
yeah well yeah and i you know i my own
of course i i have a mandatory podcast
called the
duncan trussell family hour um which is
uh yeah that's that's pretty much
i i've got some other stuff cooking i
can't talk about but that's my main
thing and i love doing it and we i've
com if i'm lucky i have conversations
like this on it
um because they're my favorite kind of
conversation to have yeah i can't
talk to people about this [ __ ] i mean
here i'm with these guys all the [ __ ]
time and i feel like
they uh heard me say a lot of this [ __ ]
for the first time
you know like you can't you can't you
know that would be really interesting to
see how this
episode performs for us because this
one's
super dear to my heart man this is like
really
yeah yeah thank you any time listen man
i know everyone says this to you because
you are in the unfortunate predicament
of being
very famous but anytime you want to just
shoot spiritual [ __ ] that everybody
reported
reach out i love these conversations i
can have them
all day long it's my favorite thing to
do so thank you it's really nice meeting
all of you and you're like well that's
on your awesome podcast
i appreciate it so much man and congrats
on everything you got going on dude i
really
uh yeah it's a joy man so so [ __ ]
able to sign off here
dude the radio thing and
like people think they're the beatles
come on i love that and
i really believe that our wild ride with
stevo podcast
just gets better and better man i
really truly think the last one was dad
the one before that t-pain i really
think that we're operating at a high
level and i'm
super grateful and as always super
duper grateful for you guys sticking
around to the very end
now i haven't said this in a long time
to
to you guys calling you the street team
but man would it mean a lot to me if you
would go
post a screenshot whatever like just
hit up duncan trussell to let him know
how much i loved this episode
and if you did too please let him know
that as well i love you guys thank you